all right another major league debut
johann
oviedo big kid from cuba excited to see
this young man pitch you know the nerves
are there he's had a chance to think
about this
he's got good stuff now the wind-up and
the pitch to javier by us
swinging a miss on a slider in the dirt
kistner tags baez out the cubs fail to
score and the cardinals are coming to
bat at wrigley field after al zaleh four
games last year two starts two out of
the pen
i mentioned one rough one against the
pirates inflated that e.r.a the other
work was
pretty solid wong makes it into second
base with two away
high fly ball right center field
playable for half
back near the track right center gloves
it for out number three
carpenter skies to center cardinals
don't score we take it for the second
inning
now you've got two men in scoring
position and the infield is back so
let's see if carotene can put the ball
in play at the very least so we're gonna
base it up the middle
one run is in contrast rounding third
here comes the throw by bader to the
plate good throw slide tag
save at the plate two run single
for victor caratini cubs lead two to
nothing
big swing at a bat for victor he gets an
inside fastball and just shoots it back
through the middle
contrast has to hold for a second to
make sure it's not caught
and then makes a great turn coming
around third base and beats the throw
from bader
who makes an excellent throw right on
the money but contreras head first dive
beats the throw to the plate by less
than the length of his fingers it just
barely beats it and the cubs take the
lead two nothing
away the batter ian half lined toward
left toward the corner long run o'neal
dives can't get it
it goes all the way to the wall hat
turns on the jets around second he's
going for three
the throw to third hat will have a
standing triple
a diving try by o'neal
he missed it it went all the way to the
corner at the 355 sign in half with
great speed
as a one out triple and a third one away
cubs already lead two to nothing anthony
rizzo with an rbi opportunity
infield in the pitch bounce to the right
side
wong has it throws home and they got him
at the plate
colt long throws out half at the plate
oviedo gets rizzo to bounce to the right
side and the gold glover
takes care of half shorter wilson
contreras and jason hayward do up in the
cubs fourth
and that ball is hit right back to
oviedo and he caught it somehow he
caught it
that was a line drive right to oviedo
and oviedo has eyes as big as can be he
can't believe how scary that moment was
as he hit that ball right on the nose
right to oviedo runner at third now with
one
down the pitch to kisner is hit hard
center field backing up
the center fielder half that's going to
be a productive out
sacrifice fly rbi andrew kisner
and that cuts the cubs lead in half two
to one as the cardinals bat in the fifth
inning
cabrera the hard throwing lefty jeremy
jeffress
throwing in the cubs pad nasty pitch
there down in the dirt that slider and a
strikeout for cabrera to start
the top of the sixth one-one to rizzo
wrapped on the ground to second another
hard hit ball but
right to long and rizzo must feel
snake bit right about now he can't buy a
hit even though he's been hitting the
ball
sharply all day long time run at second
go ahead run it first two outs brad
miller ready to step in
hit the other way base head calls in
will score in the game is
tied at two miller again
he comes through at wrigley and we're
tied to
two david bode tibet with the bases
loaded and
one down gallego two
base hits center field elmora scores
is horner but it's four to two david
bodie again
he has been very very clutchy
craig kimbrell is looking for his first
save of the season last two have been
his best two
that's why he has this opportunity he
allowed runs in
each of his first four appearances
got him looking on the curve
max is looking for the express and he
got the local
check swing did he go yes strike three
there's the breaking ball you advocated
ron and it's the second out in the
interview now colton wong
represents the tying run strike three
called cubs win
colton wong called out on strikes craig
kimbrell strikes out the side
he saves it the cubs split the double
header they win the series
save number 347.